Israel's prisons are dangerous places
for Palestinians Abdul Rahman baes just
23 years old is the seventh Palestinian
to have died under the care of Israel's
prison service since
October no doubt we have fears not only
for our son but all prisoners they're
all in this together I fear because my
son was in megido jail because there's
deliberate repression and there's no
organization in this world not local and
not the Red Cross that let us down to
give us information on prisoners
conditions the prison service says the
circumstances of Abdul rahman's death
are being reviewed there are almost
9,000 Palestinians in Israeli jails
former inmates have testified about
frequent beatings and the denial of
Medical Care the Israeli politician
overseeing prisoner conditions has been
convicted of racism and membership of an
extreme right-wing Terror organization
itar benav regularly boasts of how tough
he is on Palestinian prisoners
Physicians for human rights rights says
the prison service has become a
vigilante organization operating out of
Revenge Mahmud katanani describes the
more sensitive parts of his body the
guards would beat the 19-year-old spent
3 months in jail before being released
in the exchange for captives being held
by Hamas in
Gaza I feared going crazy most death is
easier for me they beat us in sensitive
spots on the head and in areas that
would cause disabilities seven prisoners
would sleep on the ground without sheets
water was available for an hour once a
week sometimes we wouldn't get the
chance to
[Music]
shower mahmud's three brothers are still
in Israeli prisons he says he expects to
hear of the death of one of them at any
moment Bernard Smith Al jazer Nablus in
the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer